work work work work work work work work
you know people can ariane yeah we must
you got we're [ __ ] on chin you know
people cannot do this shut up
hey hey Lex you're annoying me today
well I meet you in the parking lot you
have a lump on your head your lump on
your nose Bob just like Tom Hanks I'll
Philadelphia who's weird logic is sorry
bro with spud dead stairs go sorry bruh
Spartan no I did I did not say that here
I didn't say you go you go what happened
your face and I just what I look down
born I said I got punched in the face
and you go that's embarrassing I go yeah
well you got beat up hey Wayne yeah
Wayne McCulloch puts me in there my
buddy Chris I think you won Golden
Gloves in Boston's big [ __ ] Canada
he's so gentle and nice yeah he just
moves around with me and then then my
boy Isaac who's Cuban and just a [ __ ]
hell whirlwind 35 how many fights with
you five six six amateur fights yeah
doesn't know what he's doing well he's
better than I am so he punches me in the
face crack I've been acting for three
weeks and my timings off and I'm telling
you right now yeah you know this is what
I did I went all good all right all
right we'll see what happens when I'm
not tired when I get we still gotta beat
up a point if this may not be done
because here's the thing no one looks at
joking there you go O'Brien's been
sparring I look at it I'll [ __ ] right I
got beat up like that gay guy in Chicago
well you know I'm thinking like you're
walking down the string got beat up what
you suspect has anyone looked into it no
it felt weird but I don't know let's
just kick it so homeboy our yeah and
then Empire Empire Boardwalk Empire no
God I'm sorry vampire it just implies
Boardwalk Empire was 17 yes yes yes
so homeboy says called the cop here's
where gets so I went man that's terrible
you tell me
two guys with Magne Magne have making
America make America great the Trump red
hats
whooped his ass and lynched him around
his neck that's all what you know I'm
not gonna stand for this import export
bleach on the poured bleach on his face
can you believe say this is Magra
country yeah the correct [ __ ] crazy
right because so here's the thing the
cops went over all the video
they can't find anyone like that in the
entire radius of all the cameras nothing
here's the other thing when he called
the cops he asked the cops to turn off
their cameras on their chest
now I'm not called [ __ ] but I'm my
snout is out if I'm if I'm a hound dog
and Willie cuz cuz cuz I got it I'm
gonna be very honest I looked into it
cuz my buddy Frank posted an Instagram
about it and I and I was like jeez what
happened when I read it at first I went
for a look ahead of a world we're living
in what are we what kind of world are we
let me do a bum knee I lose this to
somebody right because obviously nobody
nobody would ever condone something like
this and it bums you out that we live in
a world like that I I'm gonna say this
I'm being very honest I'm very honest I
when I heard how it was described my
snout went out a little bit too I went
that I was like this sounds a little bit
theatrical now if he's recovering in the
hospital if he's beat up you see the
pictures of hustle mm-hmm I didn't which
was taken down the the director of
empire is it empire power empire empire
posted the picture then took it down oh
now he's in the hospital for something
he just got released but they have no
footage that doesn't that's a small
scratch him there's a small scratch yeah
recorded that he has a broken rib
apparently from all this
what's that apparently has uh it came
out that he has a broken rib from this
incident and according to TMZ when this
story broke they reported that there
were two men who yelled out this is Matt
Matt Berger country who's the n-word
yeah
and then the police officers after
investigation said that no they haven't
had any claims of something like that
happening of anyone saying that do we
know where he was when this happened she
Conway in Chicago at the subway subway M
subway so we probably got off of filming
cuz they're filming Empire right now
eating for him or something on the
attack was premeditated asleep there
here so the judgment for the letter that
the grape juice acquired I'm not
familiar grape juice I know the training
don't know the magazine the attack was
premeditated it's unclear whether
Smollett received a letter but it's
accompanied by what looks like a child's
handwriting and crude drawing of him
wearing a noose Chicago police
spokesperson told complex that attackers
did not say did not say this is Magga
country we still are saying there's no
report of that being said and guard the
racial comments homophobic slurs being
reported Chicago Police Department's
states we don't have that information
that detectives are still investigating
but so so there would be video wouldn't
there can you go back to do you watch
the first 48 you can't get away with
nothing in major metropolitan well see a
Jamaican video okay what else but it and
it's they're everywhere yeah they're
everywhere they're watching everything
hmm
that's fine Oh video the alleged season
our vehicle has been discovered but
something happened I'm not I'm not
trying to devalue him or anything like
that and I think it's horrible whatever
happened yeah I don't know what and it's
horrible yeah but my snouts up my snout
is out now what I find might find the
truth and it could be that this happened
or it didn't happen huh but but again
huh why would he make this up is my
thing why would he make well they put a
rope around his neck yeah here's my
question maybe he didn't say that and
someone else said that nope is that it
definitely said it so he said that
everyone does he said they put him loose
around my neck we find the noose around
his neck there's no tape of any of that
was there a noose around his neck when
he was on the ground or did they find
the rope that's just from him saying no
they fighting or anything
so the ant beat happen what I'm saying
is we need more details and the vid was
weird to me unless all the cops cannot
like we dude we've searched hours and
hours of video and we can't find
anything like this happening what do you
what do you guys so wait so he didn't
find any case find him in the subway he
walked into the hospital and said I was
just attacked and here's what happened
is that what how it is all I know or
didn't
attacked he took himself to Northwestern
Hospital so it sounds like he walked
into the hospital and then filed a
police report and they said what
happened he said they jumped me put a
noose around and I can called me this
that and the other thing sometimes
actors can be a little dramatic yeah and
they poured bleach on me what if he was
like really buzzed or drunk because it's
2:00 a.m. right yeah drunk and then
something happened altercation and he
kind of just embellished the story like
big-time possible but who knows who in
the woods but they're shooting my big
girl of my smells out only because if
the if there's video with there would be
video wouldn't there be a lot of video
evidence or some video evidence of two
men on update we continue to seek any
available evidence video to identify the
possible offenders in this case anyone
okay thus far we have not found anything
to be able to put out a description
tonight Chicago police detectives
expanded the search area for cameras to
be able to provide photos of the alleged
assailant in this attack thus far no
video of the alleged assailants have or
a vehicle has been discovered but
continue broaden our search I'm very
confused is it an area where there's a
lot of cameras
well it's cameras click on the footage
of Empire actor ledge see the middle one
three hours ago
this one yeah what's that looking kid
man so cute dick I'll just play the
video yeah yeah this morning Chicago
police tell Fox News they have reviewed
more than a dozen surveillance cameras
in this area where after Jesse Smollett
says he was attacked and so far they
have not identified any assailants or a
getaway vehicle police tell Fox News
that Smollett the actor was not able to
pinpoint the exact location where this
attack happened but it's inland area of
Chicago just a few blocks north of the
river very dense with hotels and
high-rises and bars and restaurants
police say so far surveillance video
does show small let in the area along
with other people coming and going and
that the actors digital footprint
indicates he went to Subway that night
like he told police police say now they
will be following up with all the
buildings in the area to see if they can
identify anyone on surveillance that
night and are also expanding their
search into other neighborhoods now
small it is an actor on the hits there
Empire created by Lee Daniels here is a
portion of video that lee daniels posted
to instagram you didn't deserve nor
anybody deserves to have a news put
around your neck to have bleach thrown
on you it's also musician it's also the
guys could you make it help me I ask a
question well for a tag and I can I
float a theory then get me the both
comes out Lee find this video guys no
because I'm all I'm saying is I'm only
working make America great again working
off the [ __ ] I'm just working off the
evidence again mega - - so - - so it
doesn't seem like the cops leave Chicago
police know what they're doing from what
I understand they've been around they've
seen some crime to get a lot of they get
their hands full they got their hands
full and they probably have some
experienced people on this case true or
false you check every you check it's a
densely populated area with a lot of
people frequent there's probably they've
looked at over a dozen video hours of
those okay and the Dozen video cameras
and they've picked up nothing okay all
good is it possible that because Donald
Trump ferments so much resentment and
hatred among people and there's a lot of
reason in my opinion to be angry at
Donald Trump I believe I'm not I've
never been a fan of his never been a fan
as you guys know but is it possible that
this is a there is a this seems to be a
movement to make anybody who wears a mag
ahaab get it out bro
you know they equate them with being
racists equate them with being you know
Nazis now that there is it seems to be a
large move like the Hat the Red Hat is
it Papa doesn't make you racist the new
syndrome no I'm saying I'm saying is it
possible that when he said this is Magne
countries and he was both red Phillies
had that he's trying to that he's that
that maybe this is maybe he got beat up
or maybe he didn't and maybe boys you
have the scar on his face is swollen and
broken ribs if you guys broke mister but
I don't know any of this I don't know
any of the details I'm not getting any
details I know yeah
Dida socks on with Nikes mystery man
[ __ ] nuts
I don't know I I don't know enough about
this to really say what happened when I
went but when I saw but it's okay to
have a little bit of it's okay to be
confused by this no I'm with a man if it
if it really went down that is not cool
out in any fast obviously it's not cool
if it went down object no I'm just
saying it's a little all of us were but
now it's now it's out my stamps out
that's all now if you had know if
there's video your snouts out because
all you're doing is responding to
evidence and you're looking for evidence
but you don't you haven't found it me
are you sniffing what nope nothing
look some hound dogs gonna track down
the blood I can't find in nothing I'm a
bloodhound
okay this is gonna be very interesting
because I want they don't find anything
what happened I don't know I this could
not very very if they don't find
anything well it's gonna be very
interesting discoveries it's gonna be
tough from cuz a lot of people are
probably feel this way
well a lot of people gonna go what the
what what really went down here that's
all trouble I sent a tweet I'll be like
you're full of [ __ ] show me the video so
you'll get more support either way he's
gonna get support I don't think he's a
bad guy he's actually doing well on the
show I don't know why you needs to do
this yeah his face is a little swollen
but don't look like ya beat up right
well no look I got beat up see my face
dude did you and I was weren't hating
someone hold you down I was head guy was
wearing headgear and I've or what
happened 16's long house 16-ounce gloves
with headgear and look at my face with
Black Panthers hats hold you down and
whoop your ass
I'm not saying but I'm not saying
anything but they were I need video bro
I don't know this one sigh I don't know
if you know you don't say though you
like my face and that was with with a
bar and with like you know it like like
your face would if you get beat up
you see marks you've you been you've
been hit in the face there are some
marks and swaggy a black and blue unless
your face is condition2 yeah that that's
not the best picture yeah are we the
only ones thinking this might be fake
what is it all over you know what sucks
that we daniel edict the lee daniels guy
that i don't know
the show he's the same guy that didn't
pay the money to your mom and ashamed
and I don't like hearing him talk about
like oh this justice cuz I feel like
it's a little thing wait what happened
remember Lee Daniels the guy that didn't
pay back Damon - a million dollars yes
that's the guy who created the show
that's guy that was on camera now
talking about like he shouldn't deserve
to have a noose he shouldn't have it hey
who didn't pay back the two million
dollars I got a start and - like
[ __ ] you the only reason you're
where he asked cuz he gave two minute
pay me in dreamer he was giving a
[ __ ] martyr that and he ended up
having to pay five minutes - yes got a
pea [ __ ] a right well you know what
doesn't help the story doesn't help the
story I don't know how I feel about this
all I know is we're gonna look like the
biggest racist of all things we're not
racists so early though so you know you
are the farthest thing from any kind of
racist in the world on brother right I
mean for real like if we if you and I
were looking down the street you saw
these as some [ __ ] to witness to him
example a right only higher Asian but if
you guys saw the two guys beating up to
a black a gay black man what would we do
honestly no no I'm sorry no we would
[ __ ] all the cops
no we would call Johri no we would we
would call [ __ ] on those [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah we close it close in
closing we don't let's go where those
guys and BC shot of him yep right 100%
we would run I would I would I would do
that meeting we would protect this
person we would protect them true or
false true being a [ __ ] right no true
dude we would Perdue would run away
wouldn't you no no you don't hang up a
black guy you know I'm saying we'd do
something no black white makes another
matter even if I don't know the story
correct
so so unless he's like he [ __ ] my
girl's ass a big girl continue what you
were doing yeah sometimes somebody needs
their ass beat but this is not that case
well you're just responding to I don't
know the case you're going you're going
wait if there's zero video evidence what
happened I'm telling you I'm balls deep
in first 48 and last night's case this
girl who is that down on her luck mood
to Atlanta from New York and short on
some change trust Russian dick for
change cuz she walked up this dude who's
a construct with black dude who's a
construction worker it was like hey you
looking to have some fun and they go
into like this this area where you can
get to the subway and it's pretty
hidden and he thought he was good and he
only gave her $8 she's like dude it's
more than $8 get your dick sucked and
he's like that's all I have she's like
[ __ ] you I'm not doing it then and he
takes her head rams into the side of
this brick wall punches in the face then
shoots her twice oh my god
yeah she's great for a second yeah it's
first 48 baby jeez first 48 baby
and so shoots her and then just walk
keeps continues walking like all good
well the cameras got it
excuse me the cameras got all of it and
they bring him in they go is this shoe
here and he's like yeah that's me and
he's like well I mean what are you doing
dude like you punched that lady shot her
and he's like well you know it's weird
because you know I got upset she won't
give my money and then makes I know I
hear two gun shots and she shot herself
and they also they lured there laughs
they're like in the back laughing like
really and they zoom in on the tape me
can see him with the gun he's a cop man
he goes I'm a [ __ ] idiot he's I'm
just an idiot you have to prison for
life yeah you should die so shitty it's
so bad but you showed you the cameras
are everywhere everywhere everywhere so
everyone what I don't want a [ __ ]
evil human me yeah you don't get away
with a lot nowadays you know is there is
there any one report anything hell
suspect this is is there any like is any
of that chin well from I see a lot
social media yeah so obviously the
magnet country thing that that raised
Mike I kind of went that that's weird
I just that was the first thing I went
that sounds like I'm dead you know
because there's a lot of hatred for
Donald Trump and it's it sounded very
convenient maybe I don't know
or does it I mean I don't think so I'm
not saying it's good I do I'm not saying
it couldn't happen I mean I really love
to see it really went over the top with
it I think you're gonna find that the
Chicago Police will find they'll get to
the bottom of this let's just put it
that way you know I'm saying mm-hmm I
think it'd be really hard course people
said that they thought it was fake you
it would hurt but by the way I don't
know what he said I know I don't
actually know what actor said people are
saying what he's
but I wasn't there so I don't know what
the actor said to the cops I don't know
anything about this I don't know so
we're we're working although you and I
are expressing opinions or at least our
skip awesome ideas you're just
spitballing we call it brainstorm where
I'm from just brainstorm in the
situation it's all it is it is such a
apparently I I know somebody who knows
him apparently he's a really great guy
and it would it just I guess it must
suck you come back to the set because
those sets become like family you're
with us all the time yeah you're on set
you're on a show man I mean again all
jokes I dab $0 for this my cousin died
because he was gay got beat up on a bus
they killed him yeah you tell me about
that yep oh so here at ha no letter
which is sent to Fox News in Chicago
with a cutout let's run you will die
black FA oh okay I was trying to put it
sometimes you know yeah man I mean let
it was send 8 days ago all right so it's
get a little suspect
first of all whoever did this not only
are they insanely stupid and because
you're racist but they're also the worst
artists in the world unless the other
three you're all draw this racist thing
is that a huge dick it looks like a
guy's holding up a tree more oh that's a
tree with the whole night we know
without kind of a noose in there or a
drill what is that that would be a gun
and a lynching this guy is the worst
artist worst ever you know it's so bad
it's like the guy is you notice the guy
obviously has a six year olds brain so
find the races with the six year old
brain and you guys how think about being
this big of a loser so you know long it
takes to cut those do you ever have to
do that and you're going after an act
hate to cut you know long the magazines
you have to find for the perfect letters
and then glue what that took an hour at
least
and then you got to draw that [ __ ]
and you're going after an any rag or row
man terrible and then you call your
buddy who's also down got done first
team all losers team a loser
no way your [ __ ] girls doing that no
go tell any girl in the world hey listen
I would love to see you but are you
getting a bunch of magazines together
and cut out the words cuz I'm sent a
hate-filled by the way I have no doubt
that this guy has gotten a lot of hate
well for sure Witter and I so weird
people still get hate like I watch that
was you're gay and you're black so we're
dudes I know they do it's just strange
to me that they still send that hate
this day and age like I watch that show
on TLC what's her [ __ ] name the girl
who went through a transition she's born
a boy but obviously clearly a girl yeah
it's a Bambi no Jesus no TLC jazz I'm
Jess I am jazz so she finally got her
surgery and she she got big off YouTube
saying how she you know she feels like a
girl and she is legit since she was you
see her as a kid just like 1 years old
and she's just like she's in a boy's
body but she just you can tell you know
so they go through all these steps they
fall her all on all through the years
and she got big on a youtube channel but
when she finally gets the surgery her
and her brother make youtube videos and
the dad goes [ __ ] why would you guys
post that like what do you mean like we
just told what hospital you gonna be
yeah and I didn't think of that and
they're like well what's wrong with that
he's like all the haters gonna show the
[ __ ] up and be furious when you try and
do something like who go out of there
when they do to show what they did it's
all show up right hospitals always been
threatening people homosexuality was
always said you know you'd hear these
things where it's like it's threatening
to the family the nuclear family to the
fabric the moral fabric or that's always
been the case yeah we still is do if
you're gay in Chechnya right now they
are being rounded up and toured their
game over
it's [ __ ] what it is man but how
incompetent how stupid do you have to be
to believe that well it's just ignorance
ignorance has been around forever dude
how about slavery Bravo yesterday sent
us a video of this transgendered chick
with an ax in a 7-eleven or some [ __ ]
yeah and just acts is to normal dude
yeah
was it an axe or was it the axe handle
Lavie was an axe right I think was
actually pretty rough yeah I still I
detect any too much dude you're [ __ ]
up my afternoon yeah why you son said to
you when I was finally amazing and
somebody will be standing there with an
axe and the persons acting that the
people don't do not on guard if you have
an axe I'm I'm either super close to you
are super far away from me my spidey
sense goes get the hell out
you ain't swingin that I got to do
dressed as a chick with an ass yeah run
you got me ready
that's why I'm always ready Sidney axe
attacks it's such a transgender woman
you wanna karna I would assume thats it
i don't think there's a ton of
transgenders that's or and how is that
just that's a relaxed
that's an axe bro it's one dude in the
face it's the other guy in the back
that's so friggin literally that same
transgender woman who got no let's go
you wanna [ __ ] bro I'll give you
broke [ __ ] yeah who's it pal
looks like a surgeon you want a suit
[ __ ] I'll give you a spoon it's
ma'am it's ma'am
he was great she was great on TV damn
this one's rough the one dudes looking
across I do gets hit right in the face
keep scrolling down yeah that's not look
at the pictures though but the guy I
kept you like Texas mouthy she none of
them died she attacked her second venom
near the door a fracture and the woman's
skull was a woman fraction woman's skull
turn on third customer shame but he
shield himself using his back cracking
ax she was arrested shortly after to get
hit by in the face look that's a relaxed
dude you gotta kill that person
you gotta put him down like a dog yeah
you have to we can't have you hitting
people the well he was knocked on the
ground with a four-inch facial wound in
fractures we'll see yeah you don't want
to sit now you don't want to take a
four-inch facial wall so don't don't
just stand there looking you gotta it's
very strange to me that yeah cuz you
know anyone comes in here believe it
people freeze in these situations they
freeze
they always be on the lookout for
anybody with a wig and an axe oh that's
why mama said I'm saying my mama said
dude she calls me dude
dude if a girl walks in has a fat dick
in the front and then axe hanging off
the back run yeah if somebody comes in
if at all or bet you tell if a large
human being with a wig and the Adam's
apple and poorly applied makeup comes in
with an axe into a 7-eleven they're not
there to buy cigarettes no you kick them
right in the dick
yeah or you do something what you don't
do is just stand there like this guy and
buy your [ __ ] Mentos and think
everything's all go some people lose
their mind they're just no this guy's
just no I don't think so I think it's
you see this guy he doesn't freeze he's
like talking I'm like oh what's up man
just like being cool
goddamn yeah you don't expect it that's
and she's what does she listen to she
has headphones in and [ __ ] yeah I got a
26 years old yeah yeah uh she pleaded
not guilty I mental health and the court
said [ __ ] that noise yeah rejected her
argument I agree how about the fact that
it's literally arctic temperatures in
most of America right now it's cold nila
is that is that seven he's at the one
yeah it's seventy I'm freezing
that's the axe later yeah really that
used to be a dude cute girl she that's a
real transgender that's so that's that's
looks like somebody went full up there
dude you hit innocent people that is
hurry I'll put you down he's beautiful
the red she looks pretty as [ __ ] there
that's why would she be the one to take
an axe to somebody boy she looks crazy
there though doesn't she oh what's
afterwards she must have lost her mind
she must have judged you know this is
she's just a bad person
no I think this is a this is somebody
that's innocent yeah I think that if you
walk in and randomly act strangers
you're not bad you're you're you've lost
your mind you're not in your right mind
that just mental illness something you
think yeah you think serial killers are
all mental illness too though well I
doesn't CC I may think that they're they
have something wrong with their brain or
they get excited off of torturing people
but that then so what I would do with
that person is I will then you put them
down but with this person it feels as
though I mean this is this this feels
like some privilege
bringing my dream boy eventually we're
gonna be able to look at someone's brain
like this and go oh you were having your
computer went crazy but I don't have
crazy well under you you put them you
have to protect them from society and
even from themselves by giamatti the
transgender acts attacker convicted of
three attempt murders grew up in a
comfortable central Perth suburb the
child of West Australian trade union
royalty the name Carl yeah his name car
after that I would piss anybody off
Amati was gifted academia would gone to
top the state in English and become a
high achiever of Western Australia's top
public school in English literature
ancient history and political science
science Wow but last month they were
forced to hear about their child's
intelligence and academic tubes and
Sydney courtrooms growing what the [ __ ]
wait yeah this is what I say oh look at
the right yeah still think she's hot bro
keeps going down well also you know when
you go through all these hormonal
changes and stuff how to [ __ ] with it
might have [ __ ] with her brain you
know for real
and look that's a crazy person look at
her
another grad yeah this is not some of
those really in the doc court 2/3 of the
downing Center Saturday once a brilliant
child now 26 year old transgender woman
all right her father keeps going down
mental illness for sure jury didn't
believe him they say they's crazy yeah
but you know you can't look in Simon's
brain but you can just say you you come
in and randomly attack people that is
not the act of a sane human being you
know it maybe it started in with the
gender dysmorphia and everything else to
begin with I don't know who the [ __ ]
knows dude what happens to people but
pretty girl
not my style I wouldn't say pretty to my
book yeah I really threw my pretty
Kellogg no she's kind of cute anymore
none of my scale [ __ ] who knows what
goes on but you know Rogan had a guy
Robert Sapolsky on who studies the brain
he's a an evolutionary biologist he
studies baboons and so and he said in in
probably 10 15 20 years when we see how
that we lock up someone like this we're
gonna go my god yeah because it's like
um when an epileptic somebody who had
epileptic seizure which flail around hit
somebody they would put them in jail or
they would they burn him and say well he
was there was demons in him he's an evil
person well he had a [ __ ] it was out
of his control and I'm fascinated with
that whole area of science as we learn
more about the brain and whether or not
we'll be able to grow problem though huh
hopefully you can fix that yeah a
weather don't make fun of my throat
problem dude doing for the listeners
all right well [ __ ] this dude so I guess
she had she found out about somebody's
suicide was friend of hers that's what
said over that I don't know man I don't
know Wow
you just can't have that no no you can't
you just can't have that I don't I like
my friend you know where we got a friend
who trains who trains all the SWAT teams
in these was a Special Forces Israeli
guy and he goes really well known and he
goes um I said I'd like to carry a gun
in case there's an attacker so I can
shoot the person the frame oh it's like
a shitty dunk whatever like some guy
comes in with a goner
and he goes ah good I know I'm sure and
you have this idea you would shoot them
and you know here's the problem is that
you're also gonna get shot I see what I
mean cuz when cops come to that scene
they just see a guy I see a dude with a
gun you get shot you're the first guy
their target yeah you don't know when
they're coming but they're coming right
away yeah I was like hmm it was a lot
that goes into I'll just wear a big sign
don't kill me this won't may I just shot
MTV's ridiculousness with
dear dick and there they showed a clip
it is not the theme was nut shots and
showed this I couldn't tell if is a
transgender person or not in this river
off in Brazil and some random [ __ ]
around the world and he or she is in the
water and it had like a seunga speed on
and a crap or piranha bytes not his dick
no heart and he's like aah
screaming but screaming like a girl but
he's not knocking it off he's just
waiting for this young man across the
river to come rip it off so I started
going in on how you know let me I think
we see that I don't think so it'd be too
hard to find ironic obviously I'm saying
how I
I think it's set up and he's just trying
to get the young kid to touch his dick
huh they're definitely gonna edit all
that's happened the crowd was laughing
and Rob is dying but they can't play
that on that look like a transgendered
like dude do you want me to look for or
no it's gonna be too tough to finding
this podcast a screeching halt but yeah
they won't hear that so what can I do
yeah don't get your dick bit by a
piranha
don't get your dong there is in the
Amazon River you know about the little
creature this swims up your tentacle
yeah and then goes chew it sticks out
spines little Spurs go read and look
that up
it's a the fish tiny like little fish
you know how we think how in movies and
stuff how piranhas go like feeding
frenzy yeah I heard it's not true no
it's not that's not that's made up
problems really don't ya Candiru the
Candiru fish really needs utensils the
story is that the fish swims upstream of
urine into a man's penis then eats it
from the inside but is there any truth
to it of all the denizens of the amazon
basin there is none more feared than the
tiny fish known as the Kandra what is
your video let's see if it's true
the reason for this candor suppose habit
of entering the human penis lodging
itself in a place with sharp Barb's and
feasting on it from the inside a horror
story that is nothing the tale has been
told everywhere from documentary on the
BBC on Planet Grey's Anatomy
and it's very clear that none of this is
true sorry but it's not clear that any
of this is true
you know I was always like me to us like
it was on value more than a hundred
years the tale has been told vision I
can't have it if penetrating your way
throughout the 1930s the camera the
counts far back is 1829 in 1829 they
believed in [ __ ] yeah of course foot
and slavery the first challenge is
identifying the fish the Amazon is home
to countless species of catfish and have
several tiny virtually transparent
species so you know what yeah there say
yea though I Pro there's piranhas no I'm
also not true they don't thought if you
drop them waters on a feeding frenzy
yeah ah there's significance again and
the vast muddy depths of the Amazon
works you know what it's [ __ ] go
down I thought this whole time uh now
piranhas won't eat you either you have
to be dead I think they're just showing
pictures of it that that's [ __ ] this
is feared as well yeah the story is
there you know they do have teeth but
they're not exactly gonna although hold
on these creatures is claimed we're even
more feared than the ferocious school of
piranhas that also have in these waters
keeps going down what about piranhas did
you but that here's the thing you can
dump with the chicken and the promise
they [ __ ] that do you ever seen that
yeah but it's daddy
I know but Google that [ __ ] already
YouTube that chicken attacks piranha
frenzy for on a frenzy I auditioned for
a movie called piranha well I've seen
that movie one I have I've heard of it
III got a callback I remember I'd be
like my lines were there's piranhas in
here you guys watch out that was the
worst
yeah
dead piece of fish there you for [ __ ]
that thing up but if you're a human
ain't happen you'd have to be a ton of
them and they don't they don't attack
you they swim away from maybe but chin
you're [ __ ] that thing up don't
really [ __ ] I think I type in a
piranha human attack never happened it's
never happened in the history of oh well
there seems to be a lot here oh yeah
right that's gotta be fake right look so
pretty easy bad it's real that looks so
bad
which one you want hold on the top one
best that one first
hold on this is the bat it says the best
always gets me like world's best coffee
I always buy it
best pizza buy it best deadly horrifying
black piranha contains disturbing video
perfect okay though it was a bad time
that happened over in catching frog
that's all they are
exact watching maybe we go that other
one Rogan used to have piranhas and you
do if you drop goldfish in they yeah
yeah yeah go to the other ones golfers
lived in that thing and I'm not a
separate the same guy adjacent hanging
I'd said death row wait what's going on
here Caymans a joke a punching came into
his face Freddie cameras what is this
look at all those fish going crazy now
if you put your finger in there that's
them [ __ ] destroying that yeah look
at very very a frenzy
you know I'm not really scared of them
anymore now you should if you put a
chicken in there they're gonna go crazy
on the chick but there's no video really
humans yeah they don't attack you that's
in River Monsters they they debunk that
whole thing it's complete [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] that well that birds getting torn
Wow [ __ ] up
holy [ __ ] let's see that bird that was
crazy what I suppose if you're a bird
you want to be careful yeah it's all
suspect that's that's caught that's a
video that's [ __ ] dude we're not
afraid of piranhas you know even grot
watts what Brett watts are that was that
woman on she swims with snorkel biggest
boom she snores with the biggest great
whites ever those people drive me nuts
respect the goddamn why humans aren't
made to [ __ ] hang out with me right
just give it to the space great man
when do yoga and [ __ ] downward dog on
a [ __ ] great white move along lady I
don't want to see this little girl all
right don't look it's over it's all
[ __ ] Cooper honest look Nile
crocodiles polar bears they will eat the
[ __ ] out of you hold on scroll down how
rare are piranha attacks the BBC points
out another six year old from the same
time state okay so six year old died in
2012 when the piranhas ate the flesh
from one of her forearms okay she got
she drowned since the five year old was
killed in a piranha attack in 2012
awesome Brazil 2011 a drunken 18 year
old film to a piranha-infested River
possibly in a suicide attempt jump died
of blood laughs loss don't buy it hmm I
think it's possible though like if you
have a big gash and you're bleeding
they don't know what it's like it sounds
like the little girl drowned and then
they'd say that's right so [ __ ]
piranha me and they're super easy to
just get the [ __ ] out of here like do
the Nats of the walk yeah don't don't
want you don't want to meet you don't
want to meet a pole
that's not fun okay obviously we know
about crocodiles saltwater salties great
way to swim with a salty how many times
once yeah you know go ahead and do yoga
on that [ __ ] great whites you'll
probably be okay but that's not go ahead
and snort me that's the problem that's
the problem with white people they see
that random ass Yogi's have another
great white now you think it's okay
right I'll look at that video I go she's
out her goddamn mind
that's me a little something loose David
Blaine tell me a story about these two
Sciences that were down they were
watching great whites been swimming of
great whites for a long time they were
they were you know filming it or
something and the great white just
turned just went and just went and
turned and grabbed them and swam off
with doing great white [ __ ] yes that's
what great whites do that's right he was
like you know what it's like this
breathe oh yeah now I'm wearing my scuba
gear they don't know what it is true now
we're all friends we're not threatening
to him that's like a woman ever my
favorite yeah
a woman in Queensland was swimming like
in Australia or whatever Quinn's swim
back to the raft she's on the raft they
surrounds raft and then they're swimming
kind of a beautiful abandoned beach
swimming back her husband watch her get
bitten in half by a great black then it
came back and took the rest of her
disappeared I dated a girl 20 years ago
from South Africa you had to go back to
her she had to go back in a hurry
call me very upset her brother-in-law
was with they were on their honeymoon
was with her sister and he got eaten
right in front of her they were swimming
in like you know shoulders and he just
he just she said
it came and just she just saw I
literally I know sorry I was like what
am I losing my voice but Jesus saw a
blood like a just a giant splash blood
and she never saw her like this it was
just a big no though I go see Rodgers I
just see yeah nah yeah
that's what happened now that's what
happened dude so look the door thing I
don't carry shark patrol you wanna see
he's only knocking no they're just
trying to open the door really yeah so
we just leave it she would you some
current events we back Brian had surgery
on his throat while we were gone yep
should be good I'm fine I'm gonna be
clear I am when that happens you're
dehydrated
I heard that are you eating a lot of
dairy I didn't have any dairy but when I
was singing for this TV show they'll do
it the guy said that's your just di
phlegm yeah he said you're dehydrated
drink water that's the number one cause
there's a lot of to diet to probably I
know either way you gotta figure it out
um this dude sent this to us
a fan emailed J this on the find the kid
email when we were talking about whiskey
apparently we don't know what the [ __ ]
we're talking about I'm both pretend
like we do yeah and this guy was like I
dude former bartender and current liquor
industry professional here bourbon is
whiskey but made originally in one state
it is now made all over the country it
must contain 51% corn in the mash bill
and the masa dough also must rest in an
oak barrel must be an American oak for a
minimum of two years to be considered
straight bourbon scotch whiskey they
don't use the E in spelling Brian can
only come from Scotland must rest in a
barrel usually an old Bourbon Barrel
since they can only be used once in the
United States for a minimum of three
years scotch is much more variety in
terms of base product than it can be
distilled from a single malt blended
malt blended malt etc the use of peat
moss is also too detailed bro
the use of peat moss also used in drying
of the grain imparting a distinct flavor
smokey [ __ ] in summary it is all
whiskey the difference is regional
production regulation and well spelling
ha boom I like that 51% corn
I thought scotch I didn't know that I
actually thought whiskey was grain was
distilled from grain
III I'm not a big whiskey guy J's a big
whiskey Japanese whiskey guy you do I'm
not I'm telling you that that whiskey
that we drank on roads
danos nice you can get if you go down
the rabbit hole with whiskey's boy you
can get some smooth beautiful whiskeys
it's just like tequila it's like
anything else a big dick you some
craftsman can make that perfect that
perfect thing where you don't feel like
you're drinking alcohol you know scopes
hasil scopa has and the bartender my
buddy Aaron over there he knows his
whiskey and if you go down the rabbit
hole with him he'll pour you have that
vintage room yes yes now that day about
our secret room they have a secret room
it's basically a speaking gentleman's
yes yeah you got to check yourself
everything's a 60s vibe 5060 vibe it's
soap and they got they got always nice
from the 30s man from thirties Japanese
whatever it's cool in there we've been
there don't we we should go there
I should go that we should go there it
seems you are drink bar can i order
there yeah it's very the bar softly just
put your hands in like that those
bartenders another [ __ ] like Aaron Aaron
and the Aaron will tell you you can tell
me whatever you want he'll just give you
a taster and you'll be like Dan there's
such variety it's crazy
well there you go with whiskey whiskey
they were taking this off thank you Eric
long thank you Eric it's whiskey so on
Monday it was revealed that there's a
glitch in apples group FaceTime app and
what happened is people were able to
call someone on group FaceTime and if
they didn't pick up you they would still
be able to hear so if I called Brendan
and Brendan didn't pick up on group
FaceTime I could still hear what he said
you could still hear what I'm saying and
I can hear what but then also if he
doesn't pick up yes way to pick up also
couldn't random people here to like
Outsiders get here if you condition if
you connected them on to the group
FaceTime yeah what so now your phone
becomes a microphone
basically there's also another trick
that people have been using with Apple
earpods yeah where they'll leave one air
pot in the room walk out and listed the
whole conversation find out so let's say
hey I was a guy you take a piss I leave
my ear pot here and you just start
talking [ __ ] about me I could hear it
it's pretty cool
I don't like any of it yep it's so scary
cuz cuz I cuz you and I a couple chatty
Casper could be trouble right the group
tech so the group takes whatever your
your your earphone what do you have to
put it on a certain setting for that or
how does that work no the new ones have
a speaker as well as a microphone in in
it so you can just leave on table walk
away and it plays I put the other one
here yeah that's all right
not terrible what else we got technology
you guys are I talk about the Jesse
small it so let's move to this year so
speaking of backstreet boys chance the
rapper and the Backstreet Boys are doing
a music video for the Super Bowl hill
halftime cover one of their halftime
commercials and they released a small
segment of what it will be well please
play this way my hot nacho they made the
original
[Music]
yeah there's my boys what is this the
greatest out of all time and they're
still doing it aren't they they're still
doing it [ __ ] they all have to be in
height though so that had that video
have you seen the Steve Carell well we
want to say that but also are they is
anybody gonna play live at the Superbowl
halftime I know a lot of people were
dropping on yeah yeah no this is from
nine weeks ago room five maroon 5 is
that a good thing a great thing I love
my round five
if somebody hit you would love them this
is one mm-hmm I'll take good luck be in
this commercial okay okay I gotta come
up with my own catchphrase
it's right doing hers let's get
commercial right yeah Pepsi it's weird
how they released the commercials before
the Super Bowl now usually you'd watch
him he'd be surprised and find out the
best ones but now they're releasing
ahead of time which I feel like is some
of them are also like little snippets of
the third one yeah as well so like the
real ones gonna be longer to have
different cameos yeah
are there any other ones those are
pretty [ __ ] good those are the two
biggest ones that have in the house
couple days I think he looks good
said head everybody a fan oh yeah I
don't know she was that hot
oh yeah stupid hot ridicuious body
really it was a former stripper bro she
was stripper
yeah then was on real love in hip hop
New York was a character on there
started rapping and blue I'm a hell of a
rapper too right now let's take it easy
but blue the [ __ ] why did she blow up
she's had you get on it's her
personality and hip hop in love where
the [ __ ] it's called Love & Hip Hop Love
& Hip Hop she could just she just had it
like she was
difference is interesting yeah she was
like was that her back in the day that
would be her whenever that she would hit
the scream you just like she's you
couldn't take your eyes off of her she
was super fascinating that's her that's
all of them are her brother actually get
younger right no that's not her ass has
got to be real natural it's not her ass
is fake yeah yeah so our titties bro he
talks about getting uh uh butt shots
yeah her sisters delicious - sister
currently has a girlfriend oh wow but
she talks about she talked about this on
Love & Hip Hop how she got her teeth
fixed because she used to have [ __ ] up
teeth like way worse than yours like oh
my teeth are great no so her teeth were
named with his terrible
her teeth were really [ __ ] up and she
got her teeth fixed and guess what she
is I'm so worried I won't suck dick the
same it's my thing I know I thought god
damn that's her sister your sister god
they're twinsies twins huh mm yeah her
sister your problem is their sister
tries to act like her and it comes off
as super gimmicky but she's hot as [ __ ]
- yeah they're both fun there's a lot of
makeup that takes a long time to get
ready I'd like to see what they look
like regular no you can she post picture
of her that's why everyone loves her
she's so real yeah she's very real stuff
she still uses coupons and she [ __ ]
dolls good for him yeah oh there you go
all right I don't well no use picked up
the worst one I just know there's
nothing wrong with it I mean you know
what I mean like thing I would think of
her as pretty there I mean those are bad
pictures yeah it's people just trying to
make him worse yeah there's the key
Jesus gorgeous no matter what you do
she's a beautiful girl
I think makeups so stupid you know girls
were sneezes works it's highlighting
what you're good hiding what you're what
you don't want
guys don't do that no no I'd be
interesting what yeah it's funny that
guys don't wear makeup in really any
high light like you guys have all their
flaws out yeah if you do wear makeup you
have a boyfriend if you were like all
during the day Korean pop stars that's
the biggest trend right now makeup guys
with makeup yeah
guys at makeup well look em rockers all
of them will make up in the 80s I mean
then in the seventies guys rockers war
yeah they wore lipstick they were all
kinds of [ __ ] and a whole lot ever seen
Bret Michaels Bret [ __ ] and Michael's
still wears makeup Jay does yes still
wears eyeliner so does the country
singer who's married to [ __ ] homegirl
Kenny Chesney no Keith Urban Keith Urban
oh those guys wear make all of them do
not a lot of me all of them well they're
there that's a yeah that's that's a very
feminine man yeah yeah interesting
they also get a lot of plastic surgery
in Korea what else you guys got this so
there is a I guess up-and-coming singer
I have personally never heard of her it
made a headway that she got a tattoo of
Harry Styles on her face for his
birthday she's a pretty girl who is
Harry Styles he's a guy who was in one
direction so he was in a boy band very
famous singer um he's on his own now but
she's she got that but she was she's
what she do haribol apparently she was
she's a singer I personally haven't
heard of her yeah never ever so a lot of
publicity yeah she's a pretty girl
though why the [ __ ] would you do that to
your frame you set to song called Harry
OC darlin
damn she don't have that many views on a
night that's it 20,000 right now
okay set to throw back to the 70s well
yeah it's not bad
so she's obsessed with that guy then
most likely she has some mental issues
for sure yeah it's weird cuz she's a
cute girl and she's pretty a little
birdie girl yep go to another song chin
maybe that's that 70s vibe man
how did drugs sure 70s probably she got
the tattoo seven he's gonna come back
without the sex
I love the old-school feeling though me
too
Amy why is that a leak at Amy Winehouse
yeah she's good I think god it's such a
shame she got that too high career with
you on her face [ __ ] you don't disgrace
your side you don't need it girl you
don't need it and do you really think
Harry's can go oh that dude yeah let me
date you leave yourself alone you don't
have a [ __ ] chain but leave yourself
alone what is she doing man that's it
that's a there's some real like trauma
there yeah I think it might be fake fake
I hope to hell no why I've got a lot of
tattoos mm-hmm your face would be way
more red than that we're just conspiracy
baby I'm saying that maybe it's fake cuz
it doesn't doesn't over there other
picture there there's that last one she
post apply the most recent there's this
she might have just released that as
promo for a song here Yeah right tight
move girl tight movies right that's how
people are honeydicked all of us and we
thought is real I'm a fan you know what
now manhood I'm back on the train I'm
gonna celebrate your music I like her
music
doesn't she look like Angelina Jolie
yeah she's like Anna Lee are Irish like
Angelina Jolie and Amy Winehouse had a
baby mmm scary eyes
I'm a fan who's cooler it's been
emotional who's that guy right there
that's Harry Styles
let me see him for a sec
[Music]
he's actually really good yeah he's a
talented do you have you heard some of
songs some good Harry Styles gen educate
look at the followers 24 point 1 million
is that good or no you know her
hairstyle oh very famous gentleman he's
an actor T in sing man especially
nowadays on his own he cooked through
that bandwidth season what band
what new direction oh you know the song
one direction once you hear this I know
you'll know this is just Harry Styles
who's the other guy made a big from one
direction it same Zayn oh yeah ah he
dimed real skinny though is he that
skinny real proper English with that
coat then yes not matte those boots
either
everyone trying to get that boy semen
that's a fact
everyone try you that boy semen can you
know song 1 I'm well you was obdurate
and having a romantic clears Odin Li
boxers face and you gotta say everybody
trying to get that boy's semen and I
didn't even know what the [ __ ] you were
saying at first I was in a beautiful
kind of trance
and I was enjoying this young man and
then I just hear terrianna
semen that way he didn't say that so I'm
gonna ask again and I see you sitting
there with your chin on your chest like
this I like like you've just ruined
everything he'd say hey babe locked up
man he's good though right he's flying
dude how does he do that
that's amazing this guy confirms you got
Lyle sometimes you got sometimes you can
fly like you got that Holy Ghost energy
dude he's bigger than Zane um
saying that this song with Taylor Swift
Zane didn't make it really big when he
left he was the first member to leave
which is why they broke up but he hasn't
made or released any music within the
past I think like 30 million is that
good Brian I don't know I don't know
that's a good-looking guy he's a well
that's a bad picture yeah he's a sexy
dude I know who this kid is
yeah he's Indian he's Indian and English
or something
he's Middle Eastern is he mm-hmm
good-looking guy is that to his Arabic
people are very good-looking and it's in
the back of his head very aggressive
yeah there's some men I what else we got
ooh tatted on the [ __ ] neck and
what's up with the [ __ ] tats on your
face what all the kids are leave it
alone well that's on his face with the
[ __ ] decoration with me well you
could grow your hair out but I'll [ __ ]
out of here with your dumb decorations
kind of dumb head it was kind of cool I
don't give up I wouldn't do it you get
tired of it
what it looks cool on him how long can
you look at here's the bomb most people
see that yo you know what I'm gonna do
that looks [ __ ] ridiculous I know
that looks pretty sick from here though
I thought must have hurt you can grow
your hair over it you know
the one on your next tricky it's tricky
25 but you're got significant a super
famous singer it's not gonna be working
in a bank so you didn't give a [ __ ] I
don't like neck and head and face
tattoos I just don't you're older dude I
know it's so stupid you're gonna get
bored you're gonna get tired of that
look the face I agree face don't touch
your ball game yeah nak if it's tasteful
I dig it special girls head god damn bro
I better be worth a couple mil you
better have ten mil in the bank to get
in ya face that to you bout now post
Malone who I listened to recently he's
actually good yes yeah but he's a friend
of us he's only as it comes to the
Communists yeah awesome yeah but but
lord have mercy what the [ __ ] man he's
got the Christ thorns over his head then
he has underneath his eyes says always
tired yeah I I'm sorry sir what's up
with the teeth what's going on there I
think those a girl that terrible doctor
oh but he's of insanely and talented
crazy they anyone who's around him says
he's like go back to one of the other
Jesus so terrible go back to that
picture before this there you go that's
a cool lawyer yeah he looks like a young
Matty Matheson that's good right there
that I appreciated right there would
just be an artist
let your music do the talking all right
you don't have to decorate your goddamn
face it's what all the kids are doing
face tattoos I hate it
your sons right into it like I like the
way he looks there I know he looks very
cool there like he looks like your
musician there what else you guys got
damn so there has been some backlash
with the Ted Bundy biopic that's coming
out with Zac Efron and Lily Collins
because people are saying that it
glamorizes Ted Bundy they always do this
and this is what gives the movie
promotion remember when Natural Born
Killers came out everyone was in up in
arms about it and that's like a [ __ ]
class that the trailer is really good
Zac Efron's really good
I mean I see why he's hot as hell on
this
what is it about this guy Ted Bundy
wishes he look like Zac Efron there
things you don't know laughs sir
I think I must be lost that will shock
you beyond your worst nightmare I am
innocent
you actually believe this garbage to you
they did all the papers Ted
how did his name get on that suspect
list here's the first guy you said I
want to come see you
I was really hoping you'd say that
this case is about catching a monster
ladies and gentlemen I am that innocent
suspect you are skating on thin he's a
smart guy sociopath wanted to be famous
yeah never really fit in who wanted to
be a politician yeah I never really fit
in though went to law school
yeah but he didn't graduate I don't
believe he was a law clerk
well no cos he was murdering yeah he had
mediocre LSAT
yeah he wasn't he wasn't he was in a
dumb ass no he was incredibly charming
in there tow a grudge sociopath and
escape twice I think yeah he did yeah
have you have you watched the tapes of
Ted Bundy on Netflix no you know me I'm
balls I have that's pretty boring yeah
yeah I started the first episode I had
followed laundry I went three episodes
like I'm kind of bored yeah he was kind
of the person that all of us and my
generation knew about and knew a lot of
details you know when you see Silence of
the Lambs and he's got a cast and he
goes can you help me with this yeah yeah
that's how we would do it yeah I think
he'd say can you help me with my boat
with my boat never see the girl again I
know and he was yeah multiple girls can
help with my boat yeah that's my girl
life someone asked you to help you with
your boat what would you do you go take
it what the [ __ ] you got your goddamn
mind no I'm not helping with your boat
yeah yesterday I was walking the the
Showtime studio and there's just
pregnant lady pretty pregnant lady and
she was caring like these too heavy
grocery bags how's it go can I help you
with your bags
I was like surprise I'm Ted Bundy he
thinks I'm a [ __ ] psycho she's like
no I'm good I was like yeah you know
what you're right you're good no it's
true
it allows us trying to be helpful I'm
like I look like Ted Bundy right now
there's that they say that people serial
killers like that spend their whole
lives figuring out ingenious ways to get
somebody to you know to catch kidnapping
dad said he had that he thought he had
like this appetite and thought once he
killed one person they'd go away but
then he it was always the next one he
would come back and 38 women ladies 38
it's such a trash can do that this day
and age because the only reason a lot of
times you got away with everything is we
then have the technology to catch
yeah the the different when also the
different cities weren't talking with
each other like the different districts
for antitrust so they said they go to
one police station they're like coming
mister people they have like three like
well how old are they like they're all
25 and under women and then this dude
would go over to Spokane Washington like
well how many do you have missing seven
well what are they they're all of their
25 anybody hold on
so I'm got to put all those dude this
county this county this count they're
all women under 26 you morons they're
all blondes what are you doing this is
the same [ __ ] guy he has damaged
serial killers yeah they're out there
but not like this yeah get away 38
you're here his quote he said something
like they said what was it what was it
about it he said I see a girl and
there's a side of me that's that wants
to take her out to dinner and have a
nice time and and and get to know her
and make her laugh and and just have
share a really special intimate evening
with her then there's another side that
wants to see what her head looks like on
a stick that's what he said that I'm
paraphrasing but that's essentially what
he said like he was as sick and as
[ __ ] awful and what people don't
realize maybe they do but you have to
always keep in mind that the amount of
pain that that guy calls to families to
mother they show the moms like when they
it's it's obviously when you have
children it is beyond the worst
nightmare your life in a lot of ways is
over yeah because you can never really
float around you can ever ever
you can never sleep soundly so he's the
amount of pain that piece of [ __ ] caused
is terrible I hope there's a special
place in hopefully he's in hell and he
was that is a man I believe who was
truly evil yeah like you know people say
it was a compulsion but no did you hear
have you on the tapes they go you know
did you have rough childhood was this he
goes no grew up with very loving family
yeah just decided I want to study but
what's him saying is that he never fit
and his friends childhood friend said he
actually was always almost like he never
quite fitted he never really he was
never able to like be a real Boy Scout
he never was able to figure it out and
they say a lot of times that's because
as a human being sociopaths don't really
feel those emotions they have to
approximate the emotions they have to
kind of like pretend
to feel those that are acting the
emotions so they'll watch somebody go
through pain or pleasure and they'll
they'll they'll kind of mimic it and you
as a human being have a very
sophisticated eye so you can kind of
look at that and go this something about
this person is off you know you meet
people and they're like there's
something off about that person and
that's a good example Zac Efron's a good
[ __ ] actor he's perfect for that role
he's amazing yeah all right what else
she is good I'm happy news story I don't
think he's that would you look when you
like a time machine because that's not
like Efron Ted oh no I think I would if
you gave me a time machine it before I
would love to have a time machine so I
could go back and kill everybody who's
ever done something like this I think
we'd have a better world that's the only
thing I [ __ ] with go back kill Adam
Lanza kill Ted Bundy kill [ __ ] John
Wayne Gacy don't not killers
kill Hitler I'd be the base Stalin buy
bigger yeah yeah you got string bigger
Brian okay should I think I find up in
ambitious enough Genghis Khan let's kill
all those guys all he had to go all
right what else you guys yeah that's her
this is a crazy story a little boy three
years old was missing for two and a half
days in like freezing temperatures they
finally found him and he told his mom
and his aunt that he had a bear friend
that protected so the kid was obviously
loving less yeah obviously yeah or he
ran away built a fire and had count that
didn't happen
no I volved this story he got lost right
and you walk in the bunch of people
research to inform they found him
trapped in these bushes they said if it
would have been like another eight hours
you two froze to death
- now zones to freaking remove bars all
three years old oh my god Eddie Bravo
chill out chill out for me for a sec you
know that kid you put on your Instagram
the drummer who's former I don't believe
it I believe he's Talent okay Eddie I
believe he's a tenor okay Eddie well he
ad contacted me so yeah he's four does
that mean more video that's impossible
yeah he's four no it's impossible
because you're used to regular four year
old not your Eddie Bravo now you're too
much dude Eddie Bravo I got my snot out
no don't say
this one the other kid I just think the
kid may be so loosening cuz right
dehydrated
I watched Jungle Book the week before
okay Wow
but that's a good memory for him to have
he's freezing out there
yeah can you a Matt they look for him
forever
I can't believe you survived that two
and half days he said only survive yet
the food on the second I touched her
rain yeah imagine that
raining freezing temperatures I can't
believe you survived very lucky from
right what was he dressed was he hit
some drag on yeah um Jack gun I said
that's what kept alive and good God he's
so cute
he weighs 25 pounds he's two feet four
inches tall what a bunny that is tearing
cold paraffin that horrible yeah he was
with his great-grandma he was at his
great grandma's house and I guess you
hear that old you're not gonna be able
to pay attention to all the kids as well
it's terrible ah don't you guys go how
about this have you seen this viral
video of a woman sitting next to two
larger people and then just being an
absolute at least I'll keep me [ __ ]
yeah the girl the Middle's being a [ __ ]
again fat people don't know that she's
not kept oh she's not that small either
she's not fit you're saying shaming
passion her fumes about being seated
between pigs
she said that out loud yes phone calls
it's frustrating when you go to your
seat there's this too like obese people
your sight I've had I don't say the
inverted my helmet god damn bro I've had
it and I swear to God I had to sit next
to it between two absolutely enormous I
was a [ __ ] sardine but you didn't say
any bad both so fat you fed him great
and and and their arms were we're
literally their arms we're bleeding into
my sex off dude and I just went you know
what this is cozy and I fell asleep
and I kind of like cozied up their fatty
fats and I liked it yes you're a twink
and those are two gay men little sling
now it was a woman and a man scroll down
this is her
the video she's pissed she was on a
phone call saying like I can't believe
I'm in this seat while she's with these
people she looks like a before takeoff
on a United Airlines flight from Las
Vegas to Newark New Jersey Norma
Rodriguez who once appeared on the dr.
Oz Show for a nurse's appreciation
episode she ain't missing a meals to the
fat Shamer o nurses travel companion was
in the aisle seat she's saying this out
loud
yes nectar it didn't in there Rogers
flagged down a flight attendant
are you fine hot another seat because
that will not be verbally abused by this
or anybody else the flight attendant
offered the fat Shamer
a new seat
what a terrible person she didn't end
there either what a mess huh she
delivers one more insult other
passengers were outraged - be nice get
beat that lady up
to pay that's what she said she calmed
to pigs after she got up of course I
mean at that point I was appalled and I
was just I thought you know travel off
the flight that's a very nasty woman she
was kicked off the soccer I know
something that would be just she's just
an [ __ ]
you could just such a stall so you're
not skinny [ __ ] now you're not Sally
Europe you don't eat salad you eat salad
before you eat okay I equate it to a
dude who's sitting between like a guy
who is a hundred and fifty pounds who
maybe is a fight done some fighting he's
sitting between two hundred and twenty
pound guys who've never fought and he
bullies them and it's like you're not
that tough in the grand context of
things sitting next to you and like like
people who like you think that person is
fat okay there are people that can you
bleed I could sit you between two people
that would make you feel real bad about
yourself very quickly
there are a lot of people that are a
little better-looking a lot skinnier
than you as well so shut the [ __ ] up and
realize where you are in life
but also you look like [ __ ] you look
like that's what I mean there are people
I can make you look like a knave no she
still looks like no my gain on the old
law on the grand scheme of all the looks
department you use [ __ ] a mean human
being she looks like she's mean she just
looks like she's a mean nasty [ __ ] oh I
hope that's not somebody's mom or
something like that no it's such a nasty
person
I'm sure kids know better than anybody
what she's about she's just a nasty
human being there are they're out there
they're out there
speaking of nasty human beings have you
seen this fight Ryan do you see this
yeah you don't for a hotdog stand right
yeah now are they attacking him no no no
he was talking [ __ ] to the hotdog person
they stated you slow get your hot dog
and get out the way we the guy got the
message and he turned around socks him
right in the face
socks all these girls
ands on TMZ i I only saw the part where
he's hitting them I didn't see what led
up to this let's wait after this Camaro
Matt this commercial once this for bras
to tell come geez he likes chance Oh
Plastic Surgeons
unfortunately the audio but boom yeah
that was a push that's what look at this
Oh huge left okay it's huge right do you
look at how big and strong he is and
then runs away or girls man I don't know
if that's big and strong he's a big dude
though yeah he's a but a [ __ ] you know
knocking out girl I like that can really
hurt you is what I'm trying to say
what's wrong with them
yeah this is absolutely TAC girl oh that
girl's probably broke her face this one
right here is like the hardest one she's
our girl girl worse yeah he turned his
body into that what he pushes her he
hits here now watched
oh yeah that's make sense this is why
your face all beat up or you one of
these kids this what happen into a
little miniature doggy hand wasn't that
what happens to this guy he turned
himself in our car this is an LA Bharani
Woojin yeah downtown away that sounds
like a Sikh name all right now it sounds
like an Indian feels like you need your
Nazi but all right all the Sikhs out
there don't be mad at me keep scrolling
down this is just the original story so
say what happened to mom
dude he's in jail he's [ __ ] hopefully
uh yeah yeah alright well that's a bad
guy he just started terrible person and
how do how does none of the guys around
do anything by the way how does no one
dude even if I saw it and I was there
too late and he went running off I would
let your fat it down and so quickly
sometimes that you're like what but
tippy Allah tell my people were cheering
they're like woo yeah you know there was
that I heard that I think there's I
think they're like oh wait a video play
they were go [ __ ] yeah but still what
three guys there's do you guys just
watching horsies
look at the flat tub if you have a flat
up you gotta be tough you guys are just
watching and of course someone's filming
too so yeah but if [ __ ] happens like you
don't know what's happening until it
happens you're like
what what what I think you've given
people too much credit Brian yeah
everyone knows women were getting [ __ ]
sitting around red they're scared of
them - the guys are watching also he's a
big dude so I probably [ __ ] that yeah
yeah well he's in jail so it's all good
but what happens to him I think he is at
four or five years I I know I think his
biggest problems are not he'll be able
to figure out a way to get a year or
maybe even like a management probation
no you're gonna deal with lawsuits so
you're gonna have a lien on any paycheck
you make for the next ten years that's
what I would say you're in trouble
you're not getting a job either good
luck finding employment can you imagine
may as well move to another country
piece of [ __ ] you're not gonna get a job
who's gonna hire you all right what else
yet this right here a local TV station
in Pittsburgh
oh this was funny they had Tom Brady on
that ticker as a cheater all right don't
you know and sheeter nice to either for
God so the guy that worked at the
station was eventually fired they do
eyes for that they fire them stupid
total ears though how long did the guy
work there [ __ ] out of me I have such a
huge problem with pizza I root so
actively root against Pittsburgh any
Pittsburgh team because the the I wife
performed there many times and I'm not
kidding the Boosters they say don't make
fun of the Steelers on playoff day if
they're playing nobody's coming in your
show and also if they're playing
anywhere near the time you're doing that
everybody shows up in Pittsburgh gear
they're so [ __ ] fanatical about [ __ ]
off far I can't stand it when do not so
many tickets no end up when the Penguins
won the Stanley Cup I think or they were
they were God I was there I was eating
in a [ __ ] restaurant I'm not joking I
heard the whole street light up
everywhere I was like you guys [ __ ]
take it down a notch and you don't like
that this no I don't like the name come
to my [ __ ] stand up when the Steelers
were playing I don't like being trumped
by the steel
yeah this is something I mean come on
bro you shut up
he's trying watch counting a sudden
whoosh ah do you honours a long time ago
I loved the Pittsburgh Steelers yeah you
would is that it dudes take it down one
more real quick
is there one more don't worry I just
wanna know what your opinion is on this
apparently this is a thing now men's
harnesses of fashion yeah I just can't
he's fast forward two years that's
Michael B Jordan who's one of the
hottest actors right now what is that
it's a weird strand also said he'd do
his thing against where Josh here and
then that's just a meme I can't get down
this guy your guy your ice later dude
also I've handed chicks he's great this
guy Catholic right dumb what is a
harness what does he do it's just fast
holster without guns so what do you just
put it on and then that should thing be
but does that pockets or anything no no
it's literally like I have nothing in
common with anybody wears that so high
that's you know me I like my fashion but
that is a tough hard core right yeah
that probably hard note for me it's just
are you cool with it chin do what about
what about the big satchels across the
front I think this is kind of like a
finger
similar to that dudes and says well I
had that the brace thing so you still
wear that brace thing not anymore
then help really helps wearing gloves in
in a box
people try come up with new [ __ ] to
stand out he cocked with say there you
go there's original whoo I heard the new
documentary at Sundance came out about
him molesting kids is so terrifying and
they have so much evidence his family
suing them but people were like getting
up and walking out theater it's so
damaging what yeah
they had counselors in the theater as
well as after justice it's brutal slurs
shut up I guess they got beat of him
sucking kids off no don't say that
what that's what they made it sound like
it's bad all right of course he touched
kids were we talking about what do you
know talking about that guy Jordan Peele
is doing a documentary on Lorena Bobbitt
three-part series you guys on yeah
remember the writer Bob
take off yep yeah after I raped her no
he did rape you raped her came home and
he was drunk and he had done this before
and he sodomized her and that's what has
a big behind she went to lab
[ __ ] went to sleep took a knife
cut his dick off and threw it out of her
window on the highway and they found his
dick and after like 9:00 our operations
sewed it back on yeah he did well and
she drove and threw it out the window I
don't know what made you bring up that
chin I said you guys are talking about
documentaries so I spend my hearing
about it that'll be cool and they're
photographed together right there Wow
that's them together that's a while ago
oh look at that dick cutter she said
[ __ ] you he was a piece of [ __ ] anyway
get your dick off bro God those 93 old
school well guys are so serious about
their dicks I got the guy's book kills
us rhinos no men will make an entire
species extinct to keep their dick hard
true you know I mean that it chin that's
it all right dude Brian you're off the
office awesome we can come see me
Thursday Friday Saturday this Thursday
Friday Saturday and then I'm in San
Diego February 7 8 & 9 the following
weekend come see me there I'm at the
American comedy club and then February
21 Vancouver Vogue theater one night
only one show only come see me I'm dumb
chopping it up chopping wood chopping
wood like Lorena Bobbitt for March just
DC end of March tickets went on sale DC
improv March 28th through the 30th get
tickets now at evac a.com yeah this is
the fun kid we're out